hello and welcome to the video i called
everybody looks like markiplier notice
that i didn't call that markiplier looks
like everybody because everybody seems
to look like me it's not the other way
around my name is markiplier and if you
didn't know what that means
it means i'm multiplying all right
cut that out cut it kill kill the video
kill it shoot it
so it's common knowledge that many
people
fictional characters have a tendency to
look like me i don't know if it's just a
certain way that people draw
characters for cartoons but there is a
resemblance in some of these characters
that have been collected by amy
that kind of tend to look a bit like me
so let's go through a list of people not
real people maybe real people that have
a tendency
to have markiplier type qualities
markiplier-esque
if you will this one i actually don't
know okay
so i don't want anyone to be mistaken
about this i wasn't
actually wearing a shirt that's very
similar to this i don't know what's in
that guy's neck
sack um but this was a common thing
during this video whatever it was i
think was the ear piercing video
uh in some channel that will never be
now notice i don't have as prominent a
butt chin and really there's like an
angular difference between our jawlines
and clearly this dude doesn't have a
piercing so
i don't know if you could what's in the
bag
i know that's probably like a character
plot point for this dude um but what's
in this
it's really bothering me that someone
carries a sack around
i have to know okay was it chris
whatever chris mclean
main antagonist main antagonist
what am i a villain to you he was
arrested at the end okay spoilers hey
alexia
block out all the spoilers and block it
out with a big pair of sunglasses
okay what's in the bag what's in the bag
what's in the bag what is this show
aside from being the show's host what is
this show
extreme torture what narcissistic
tendencies
that's not me what's in the next sack
bag no bag what's in the bag neck
neck neck bag or bag neck bag what's in
the bag
what's in his bag what's in his bag neck
neck neck bag neck no one
comments on the bag around his neck
probably his baby teeth or someone's
baby teeth
i don't want to know okay well i could
see it
and i could see it i don't know about
main antagonist
but uh it's all good okay so i'm gonna
rate i'm gonna rate these basically
on a scale of one to ten for ten being
the most like me and
one was my scale being the least like me
okay so a lot of people saying that they
think to seem this
person is a lot like me but in reality
you gotta go based off of personality as
well
um so main antagonist i'm the hero i
think we've all determined that
pretty much straight up i'm the hero of
this story
so not like me at all i'm gonna put this
one at a solid two
there is some resemblance there with the
hair parting and i'll give it that for
the like
the hair color but the skin tones are
completely off like this is completely
off this is
not even remotely close okay so this is
probably one of the first ones
that was pointed out maize hues
from fullmetal alchemist who goes on to
live a very
long happy life where nothing
happens to him
i mean this one is uh uncanny like it's
pretty much straight up i know that
anime well i don't
i don't appreciate this insinuation
but you know this one i'll give a solid
eight i'm gonna give this a solid eight
because
it was one of the first so it's got a
nostalgia factor to it it's kind of like
okay yeah i can see that um because also
people have been saying it for so long
this is way too close
um but yes i could see this
i could see it being there also we're
both alive
so i gotta give it points for that
beautiful day for rain who anthony
garabay
five anthony who [ __ ] anthony garabay
five who the hell is this
okay so there's a fundamental problem
with uh this resemblance that i don't
think many people are probably clueing
into
some of you may be like oh yeah that guy
kind of looks like me
um you'll notice head size sheer cranial
capacity
i'm not saying that his head is small no
his head is normal size his head is
perfectly
normal sized i have an absurdly large
head well there's some facial
resemblance here there's definitely some
facial resemblance
i think that his beard is is more
complete than mine
that's definite well this is interesting
fight med bag med bag okay
med bat med bag
med bag med bag med bag okay i'm
inspecting you
i don't like that my voice was there but
yeah no cranial capacity is really
lacking i don't know if it's because my
brain is huge
it is my brain is so big my brain is so
god damn big and thick skull
and i have dense bones i have very dense
bones um but also just uh
like there's some resemblance i'm gonna
give this uh uh uh uh
uh uh uh
i'm gonna give it a yeah just like can
uh lixie this is probably not gonna make
me feel good
once i see it later um but can you just
do like take
this picture and then overlay my head
try to match up our face
and just like the upper half above the
eyebrows just really notice
just how [ __ ] absolutely enormous my
goddamn head is
uh yeah that doesn't feel good man
anyway six out of ten
okay what's this one okay apparently cgi
right right right
[Music]
i don't know about young but
right you know there have been less
flattering comparisons that have been
made today
but
[Music]
really you think
i mean if you insist
i'll uh
yeah i think there's some resemblance
here if this is how i look
when my hair starts to turn gray or when
my hair fully goes gray
like i'd be okay with this
i'm gonna be okay with this
that's not a bad luck i'm gonna give it
a tenuous
10 out of 10 because i don't know if
something else takes the place of a
better resemblance in this list
i'm gonna give that 10 but right now i'm
gonna give you ten kernel
i'm gonna give you ten for now but it
could be replaced if there's better you
don't mind if i go
shopping around do you anyway let me
look at the comparisons
no one's made this comparison okay so
this may not resonate with other people
because they
they there hasn't been any direct
comparisons that people have made
which is sinful and i believe that you
are all terrible
[ __ ] and balls twitter and disagrees
yeah okay 10 out of 10 but tenuous
for now okay so this one i didn't see i
don't see this one
i think that this is probably the
farthest from the truth some people have
said
oh wait no that's right because some
people said like if you put glasses on
it kinda looks a lot like me but i
still don't think it's quite
there
put glasses over me like saying put
glasses put those glasses over
my face morph my face to match that
expression here
uh the three i'm gonna give it actually
i'm gonna give it a one with no glasses
three with glasses and that's all i'm
gonna give it yeah
that's not that's not even close what
the frick is what the
what the frickin what is
what is what what
wha what what in what were in what world
in what world in
do you think my nose is that big is that
what you think because okay you're just
like okay glasses
and long face and beard or marble see
that's how bad it is that's how you
sound
where where is this resemblance i see
more seth rogen in this dude than me
what what are you pulling this from what
are you even what are you even trying to
do
here what are you saying about me i'm
not saying that this dude is
horrendously disfigured and ugly
but also just what the poop elixion
censor that what the hell what is this
what are you
who are you who do you think you are i
don't even know what to say to you
anymore
i don't even know who you is this is
just
so wrong in so many ways that i can't
forever forgive you
i will actually never forgive you i'll
never zero
zero negative one negative 10.
let me see if anyone was doing a
comparison
no what is this what is what is that
stop stop stop stop go away this is
terrible
why was that
you have some explaining to do you think
you can just go
on the internet and do whatever you want
no there are
consequences for your actions
there are consequences
oh lexie just put an indistractible
promo here i can't even
i need a few minutes i need like a
minute okay just put a nice distractible
promo okay make it really nice in
explosions lots of explosions okay
cool tell them about the link in the
description there's gonna be a link in
the description
more explosions
okay thank you all right next this one
is occasional it was more when i had
long hair i've gotten this
you know here and there yeah that's a
decent one but really like
there isn't too terrible much
resemblance other than
widow's peak high forehead dark hair
patchy facial hair okay now i'm starting
to feel like there's
if you break it down like that then yeah
there's more resemblance but it really
only comes out
when the long hair is there right now
i don't think that really there's that
much of a resemblance
other than longer face patchy facial
hair
kind of similar nose i guess oh yeah and
amy wanted me to
mention something right and and also we
have the exact same
stomach scar or a pretty similar one
i have i have the exact same scar right
there pull up a picture of my scar if
it's available or
i i could show you i have the exact same
scar
right there so okay there are some
similarities but all of it is conjecture
i'll give it a i'll give it a five
because it could go either way
it's like it's five but imagine the five
is at the top of a mountain and it's a
ball that could roll down the hill
either way depending on the
circumstances
and influenced by your opinions okay
this is probably a new
newer one this is on the list i don't
know who's been saying this
but there's this one is probably the
farthest from the truth
mostly just because like it's
just long face like if i if i
gray like this in this pattern maybe but
in all honesty there's a there's a
certain in the comic if you haven't read
invincible there's a certain thing in
the comic
where there was like a different art
style so so
omniman's son his name is mark also
but there was one it's not really
prevalent in this version of it but
there was
um god damn it like when
in later invincible there was a
different art style and then
when they drew mark grayson then
he had a like a more pronounced widow's
peak and
and he's like half korean which is
that's me that's the recipe you need and
a cartoon version of me that's pretty
much the only recipe that you need
in the normal version i think even in
the animation it's pretty far off the
truth but
omni man i don't see you haven't watched
invincible though it's good if you
haven't read the comic either it's
pretty good
anywho man i don't see that one i'm
gonna give that a solid
one get a little one all right so um
i think i think everyone has
a very strong opinion it's to the point
where this picture doesn't look right
anymore
you know what i mean i look at this
picture and it doesn't look right
something's a little off about
that uh you know
it's just um yeah it just don't seem
right well
all right let's go let's let's take off
the boxes okay hair color
sure hair line no there's no widow's
peak there that doesn't work
eye color my eyes aren't blue so you
know you got that
right out the window hairy chest i do
not have a hair chest pink nipples my
nipples are brown
this is just there's no resemblance here
there's no resemblance it's impossible
to get any sort of
you know conjecture about this
um i think that
that's oh no did someone oh no
i don't know did someone deep fake mute
this because
there's no way we could have any of this
but there's no way we could have any of
this anyway
okay if you want to find it you can find
a deep fake of me as lord farquaad
i have nothing to say about this we
don't even need to give this one a
number
because it deserves a letter instead
the hell is what that
one whoa jack that
one whoa jack that one i'm gonna have to
look up the reference for this one
[Music]
you know this isn't able to look alike
because i think this is based off of a
picture
of me uh i'd have to go way that
way down in my instagram i think it was
on instagram
i don't know where i don't know when i
don't remember anything about it
i don't know who i am i don't know where
i am i don't know what's going on i
never learned math as a kid
i never understood how stars were formed
i wish that i could
go to mars real bad this is not worth it
anymore this has stopped
being worth it elixir and do another
distractible promo but a quick one just
super quick don't put a lot of effort
into it put
the least amount set a timer for five
minutes and do five minutes of work
i couldn't find the actual picture
itself but it's in the same
moment as when i made this one but it's
straight on and i
i don't remember where that is but
i don't know why i did this my instagram
was a very different beast than it is
now
back in 2014. you know i was a different
human then
but i think that's actually what this
picture is based off of alexian if you
know what this picture is and you can
find it please
place it right here and then overlay
this meme
okay cool thank you and then of course
metro man okay now
i know especially this
i know that i said that kfc colonel was
10 out of 10 exactly like me
but there is no creature in animation or
in the real world that is more
[Music]
there's more me the
this this is the quintessential picture
this is the one this is
this is just this is just the one i
i think we can all agree that if i were
in an animation
these would be my most distinguishing
features and this would be who i am
currently you have to sit with nine and
you have to settle for that because 10
out of 10 belongs to metro man
thank you for letting me be who i be
because i am who i be
okay so that was all the lookalikes well
there's more i'm sure you guys know of
more things or creatures or entities or
you could probably look up
rocks and genuinely see versions of me
in them
you could look up at the clouds and you
could probably be like hey it looks like
markiplier you know you're out in the
woods and you see some tree bark
and you're like hey that looks like
marlboro you know you're on the road you
see some road kill
you look at it close you get sad but
then you're like hey it kind of looks
like marker bar you know i get it
everyone looks like markiplier i have no
conclusions about it but
i get it so thank you if you have more
look alikes of where you randomly see me
in random places all over the world then
write in the comments and then tweet at
me and then bombard me on social media
because
that's the best use for that
and now i've just cursed myself i've
cursed myself for all time
but in the meantime thank you everybody
so much for watching if you want to do
more
if you want to do videos you go out
there and do them you know
if you've ever wanted to make youtube
videos go out there create things
you've been talking about it forever why
don't you go out and do it come on
it's easy you got a phone you can make
whatever you want
get some friends to help you out with it
have a good time post a video start a
channel today
you never know where it's going to go i
went from
not looking like anybody in the world
and then i was like everybody looks like
me
so thank you keep that in mind to keep
it up
you never know you might like it so
thank you
and as always i'll see you in the next
video
bye-bye